[Music]
a real-life haunted hotel a fire
director sneaking back on set in
disguise a car crash near a road sign
that looked like the handiwork of the
devil even when horror movies aren't
very scary sometimes the stories behind
their productions absolutely are
the new mutants was supposed to explore
a brand new exciting corner of the x-men
film universe
this would be the first legitimate
horror release in the history of the
franchise
director josh boone oversaw production
in 2017 for a projected april 2018
release date cleverly or perhaps
foolishly timed to coincide with friday
the 13th everything seemed to be lining
up nicely until the post-production
process began you have a whole bunch of
really traumatized teens
that was when the first of several
release date delays occurred with the
new mutants initially postponed to
february 2019 to make room for lengthy
reshoots that were reportedly meant to
make the final cut even scarier this
worrisome but by no means fatal
development quickly got worse and worse
as the delays continued and the reshoots
never actually happened then a planned
april 2020 debut was derailed thanks to
the kovid 19 pandemic and ultimately the
new mutants died a quick death in
theaters in august 2020 instead perhaps
something weird was going on at the old
mental hospital where the film was shot
as boone told ign in 2017 that every
crew member reported strange happenings
on set though the director himself
remains skeptical
the 2010 take on the wolfman was already
off to a turbulent start when original
director mark romanek left during
pre-production a mad scramble ensued to
get a new director signed on so that the
film could still come out in 2009 and
reap the rewards of a buzzy cast that
included benicio del toro anthony
hopkins and emily blunt by february 2008
joe johnston had signed on with filming
set to begin just a few months later but
things only got scarier after the
initial principal photography reshoots
were eventually enacted that lasted for
a whopping six months and drastically
overhauled the film perhaps most
baffling of all was the indecision over
the score danny elfman's original
compositions were discarded and he was
subsequently replaced by paul hasslinger
but hasslinger's score didn't pass
muster either so elfman's music along
with new material by other composers was
brought back
the tepid reviews for the wolfman made
it clear that the final cut of this
creature feature wasn't particularly
scary but at least there were plenty of
frights in the tortured production
history
the supernatural horror flick the
innkeepers takes place in a haunted
hotel so director ty west was looking to
shoot in a spot that would enhance the
spooky atmosphere that's when he got the
idea to return to a location he'd used
in a prior film the yankee peddler inn a
haunted hotel in torrington connecticut
west had first encountered this hot spot
while making his 2009 film the house of
the devil and he ended up experiencing
some inexplicable events while staying
there as he admitted to the morning call
i'm a skeptic spending time at the
yankee peddler was the closest i've come
to believing you know i was like i
should write a movie about all the [ __ ]
that happened when we weren't shooting
house of the devil and that's what this
movie is and then they let us go back to
the actual hotel and shoot there
years after the innkeepers finished
filming lead actor sarah paxton told
dead talk news that she'd had several
weird experiences while filming the
movie inside the hotel including a tv
inexplicably turning on in the middle of
the night she wasn't alone as she
claimed that nearly everybody who worked
on the movie inside the yankee peddler
had something strange and frightening
happened to them clearly ty west was
playing with fire when he filmed a
haunted hotel movie inside an actual
haunted hotel
1956's invasion of the body snatchers
and its 1978 remake are two of the most
famous sci-fi horror films in history
but lightning didn't quite strike again
a few decades later despite the presence
of actors like nicole kidman and daniel
craig the 2007 remake the invasion is
far less revered it scored dismal
reviews and tanked at the box office a
fate almost as petrifying as the twisted
production behind its road to getting
released while oliver hirschbeigel was
the credited director lengthy reshoots
featured scenes written by the wachowski
siblings and directed by james mctigue
unusual filming techniques emulating
documentaries apparently went over
poorly during test screenings
necessitating the reshoots and a 12
month delay from an initial august 2006
release date the production turmoil was
exacerbated during the reshoots when
kidman suffered an onset car crash that
broke some of her ribs in the end no
amount of retooling could make the
invasion anything resembling a
critically acclaimed darling
before he directed 2016's doctor strange
scott derrickson was the filmmaker
behind deliver us from evil a horror
feature about demonic possession and the
idea of terrifying forces lying in wait
in plain sight the movie was based on an
actual new york city cop who supposedly
had real encounters with the
supernatural derekson's attempt to
convey these concepts didn't result in
much in the way of critical acclaim but
the onset atmosphere was plenty dreadful
i've had a darkness growing inside of me
like a [ __ ] cancer in a set report by
bloody disgusting derrickson emphasized
that deliver us from evil was filmed in
authentically grimy locations with many
scenes captured in intentionally cramped
spaces this was all done to provide an
intimate air on the set while also
trying to ensure that deliver us from
evil wasn't sanding off the edges of the
real world locations it was supposed to
evoke but this resulted in a cramped
filming space that couldn't have been
easy to act or work in there's a
commendable dedication to realism and
intimacy in this approach so it's
unfortunate that it didn't actually
result in a spookier movie
if you only looked at the critical
reception of the possession you'd
probably come to the conclusion that
there's nothing terrifying about this
sam raimi produced flick a pg-13 rated
movie dropped in the final weeks of
summer 2012 the possession hasn't left
much of a lasting mark on american
horror but its behind the scenes
troubles have become a tad more infamous
while trying to make a film about a
demon and a haunted dybbuk box the cast
and crew ended up having some truly
spooky encounters themselves while
speaking with the hollywood reporter
leading man jeffrey dean morgan recalled
how there was an assortment of
unexplained frightening events during
production including lights exploding
and a feeling of cold wind on a closed
set even more mysteriously a fire burned
up all of the movie's props just a few
days after principal photography was
finished including the dybbuk box itself
as morgan explained it was investigated
and there were no signs of arson no
electrical fire come to your own
conclusion about whether or not anything
truly supernatural was going on but
there's no denying that making this film
was a blood curdling experience and you
have
this mysterious entity coming in and
being part of life the primary
antagonist of the ring films is a dead
little girl who perished when she was
drowned in a well it was a grisly demise
that informed a popular pair of horror
titles in the early 2000s and behind the
scenes in a series of eerie coincidences
life imitated art on the set of the ring
2 in 2004 as reported by made in
atlantis the set was flooded one week
into filming the issue was a mundane one
a simple burst pipe but having such a
disaster occur on a movie about a little
girl perishing from drowning was enough
to put the people working on the film on
edge director hideo nakata who also made
the original japanese version of the
ring was spooked enough that he brought
in a shinto priest for a japanese
purification ceremony but this wasn't
the end of the liquid-based calamities
for the ring too as a few weeks later a
jug of water exploded and further
flooded a part of the set that had
already been underwater in the last
catastrophe so that's two water-based
disasters for a film that involved a
young girl who had drowned in a well and
we've yet to mention the strange
behavior of animals like bees and bugs
that occurred during production reviews
criticized the ring 2 for its lack of
scares but those needing a chill up
their spine can easily be stated by
these onset horror stories
we can thank the movie mocking tv show
mystery science theater 3000 for the
fame achieved by the 1966 film manos the
hands of fate an ill-advised attempt at
a horror movie manos didn't provide
scares but it did inspire plenty of
unintentional guffaws with stiff line
deliveries bizarre costume choices and a
never-ending opening credits sequence
there are more inexplicable parts of
this no budget movie than there are
stars in the night sky and behind the
scenes it had a truly tumultuous time
getting finished many of the hardships
had to do with the director fertilizer
salesman harold p warren who also played
the lead character michael warren could
only muster up nineteen thousand dollars
for the budget which ensured among other
limitations that cinematographer robert
guidry couldn't obtain proper lighting
or redo subpar shots it also meant that
guidry wouldn't be getting paid
meanwhile warren's disagreeable behavior
towards the crew included throwing a
slate at guidry and screaming at the
women hired to portray the wives of the
villainous master and the master
wouldn't approve
the sights on display in 1996 is the
island of dr moreau are supposed to make
your blood kernel and offer an ominous
warning about meddling in god's domain
but far more petrifying is the saga of
how this h.g wells adaptation was
realized the film was a passion project
for director richard stanley but his
refusal to attend production meetings
and clashes with cast members led to him
being replaced by john frankenheimer
after only three days of filming but any
hopes that a new director could write
this sinking ship were sadly dashed as
dr moreau fell into even greater chaos
just like stanley frankenheimer also had
trouble with hot-headed leading man val
kilmer but that was nothing compared to
marlon brando in the title role he
reportedly came up with strange
character choices refused to learn his
lines and occasionally just couldn't be
found on top of all that stanley was
later able to sneak back onto the set
get dressed up as a man animal hybrid
and covertly participate as an extra in
a key set piece who needs the ominous
words of h.g wells when you've got an
unforgettable filmmaking gonorrhiz story
like this one
the omen was a pop culture sensation
when it was released in theaters back in
1976. the story about a father grappling
with the fact that his son maybe the
spawn of satan wasn't without its
detractors but it was largely well
received for its creative frights and
committed performances from actors like
gregory peck but even the most ardent
fan of this freight flick is bound to
admit that the on-screen chills are
overshadowed by some seriously scary
happenings that occurred while making it
these odd occurrences are legion one
involved a sequence in which rottweilers
attacked peck's character things went
wry when the dogs refused to stop
attacking the stuntmen when they were
instructed to do so another peculiar
event occurred when the crew members
went out to get dinner only to learn
that the restaurant had exploded earlier
that day and even after they left the
set horrific events befell key members
of the cast and crew the most tragic
incident was that of a special effects
designer losing his wife in a car crash
that proved eerily similar to a death in
the film he claimed that it occurred
near a road sign that indicated that a
town called omen spelled with 2ms was
66.6 kilometers away with no shortage of
scary events connected to the making of
the omen there will probably always be
debates about whether or not the literal
devil was behind it all look at me
damien
it's all for you
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]